okay
welcome to this live stream we are doing
a design review incremental language
development for
language it's been a few weeks i think
since we've done one of these because
we've been in the middle of
our summer school and other programs but
anyway we're back
and um getting ready for the next
version of woven language
so first topic geo raster
yes so this is a suggestion from
uh christopher and we have christopher
shady
and brett to discuss this today okay
um so i think the general idea here is
to have uh a more prominent way of
exposing the
geo information attached to an image
so right now when we do the image it has
meta information
on the ranges of coordinates it covers
but um christopher is suggesting that we
create a new head
geo raster to attach that information as
a second argument
so wait a second so the basic point is
you're trying to compute okay what
remind me what are the operations so
there's a
geo raster apply which is applying
things
in the appropriate coordinate system or
what
uh right so this is a generalization of
image supply so we can
do operations on the geo image but
taking into account the coordinate
information
right well okay so christopher i think i
think um
just rejoined here can can you introduce
this a bit
yeah so i mean basically uh right i mean
as jose said the basic point is just to
have geo-referenced uh images
which is already possible right now
through the metadata field
of of image which is how like a geo
image works
it returns you know geo-referenced
images using the metadata field
um but so the issue is that uh for
operations on geo-referenced images
uh there are various fields that and
also behavior that you need
um like that they need to specify when
doing operations
like image assembly for example if you
have multiple geo images
they could all be assembled like you
could have a geo raster of a list of geo
rasters for example
and that could assemble the things in
the right places relative to each other
sure or or for another example let's say
you're multiplying together two images
in different projections and you need to
say okay what's the resulting projection
going to be and what's the resolution
going to be and so on and so on
right or like you could even multiply
you know two image rasters that are
different dimensions because you know
they're going to be reprojected anyway
so
there's a lot of extra stuff you need to
to provide
also there's stuff like um you want to
be able to have units um
and so on um so basically the sort of uh
the the general sort of design
here which there are some issues with is
that
uh you know there's a head georaster
which represents you know geo-referenced
raster data
and you can sort of like you do with
graph you can kind of
change uh things like the projections
and and
and so on using uh you know the function
georaster and options
um and then the main functions let me
see i think the main the main
function for uh uh for for
doing operations is geo raster apply um
which basically give it a function um
and then you give it some number of geo
rasters and then it will you know it's
like image apply
now the main issue here is there's the
question of how
is the geo raster sort of presented
to this um you know to the function that
you're applying so for example the
function is plus
because you want to add together these
two pieces of raster data
um then you know the question is what
fun
what what objects actually get fed into
plus so you might say something like oh
they could be two images that have
already been sort of reprojected
um but then the issue is what happens to
for example the uh the unit data
will get destroyed in that case or maybe
you could do them as quantity arrays and
so on
and then that data isn't destroyed but
other
things like efficiency for example if
they're stored in some numeric array
then that serve gets destroyed by
putting them in
right you want the operations down on
the image but then you want to
reconstitute the metadata afterwards
well right but for example let's say the
function is times
right then uh i mean i guess you could
have a special case for times but it
could be some more complicated numerical
combination of two images
and the question is what happens to the
units i don't know what
happens to the units but what happens at
least to the the um
uh location information is it presumably
gets reconstituted afterwards
well right i mean i think that this
function you know given given some
some gi rasters it needs to make a
decision or be given information in the
form of like an option
about what the sort of resulting
projection dimensions
uh range are going to be
okay but that just has to be heuristic
but also i think
one big factor is to understand what's
the overlapping region
right christopher is is that where
mainly this is coming from
things like plus or times that you're
mentioning
really needs to know what parts of the
images are overlapping
no right right i mean i think that the
default behavior would almost certainly
be
right to to to i mean all these rasters
need to have an alpha channel because
basically if you have some
some uh if you reproject something it's
odds are it's not going to end up as a
rectangle in the new projection
and so you need to you'd have alpha
channels for everything and so right i
mean i think that the right solution is
to just
uh only you know by default only uh only
return the the overlap um although maybe
you could imagine having other
options for that but yeah well but what
about i mean
aren't there other functions that have
like for example if it's a times
operation
is there is there a
you know the extension of the okay the
two images they cross over in one place
but in the other places they're not you
know the obvious thing to do is to have
the identity
be that the times be multiplied by an
identity element
in the place where there is no second
image so to speak
does that make sense is that is there
anything well but
like the thing is okay maybe that works
for times but what if the function is
some pure function
that's you know hash one plus hash two
divided by
hash one minus hash two or something
like that right it's like
well for the plus it doesn't have to be
an output well whatever the alpha
channel does i mean
if one can make it work in other words
the question is
what is the padding of a geo image that
does not extend over the region
of the final geo raster so to speak in
other words
if there is a geo raster and it is
combined with another geo raster
and the resulting geo raster is
presumably
always well i don't even know what's
happening here like like for this
if there's some other geo raster that
comes across like this
the combined georester has a rectangular
outer boundary
but then it has some region that is
actually populated is that correct
in your image there is a background
option that controls the color that you
want to use for those cases
a geo image currently returns image how
is
that information propagated into image
now
well for example you can ask for the
world
in the orthographic projection which is
a circle
so the areas around that um
uh region will come up with so
geoprojection
orthographic is that right yes why
doesn't that auto complete
that's a bug
i think it did at the end
does it all work there by the way
i'm i'm thinking it will i usually use
world but it'll probably be a little bit
weird though with um
orthographic uh
it didn't try world
quotes world yes
is that a really accurate picture of the
okay
okay so that has white or is it
transparent
i think it's transparent okay color
separate that
result right so this is another issue
though
is that so you could uh
you you could sort of set it up so that
the images that get provided
to you know to the function set of
geoapply are just images with alpha
channels but the problem is those images
you know it's very common that you'll
have weird numbers of bands
like you know eight bands or you know
two bands
stuff like that and so a lot of the
image functions get very confused if you
give them you know a three band image
where the
you know the third band is the alpha
channel for example
so the basic problem is that the the
images have lists of bands
not associations of bands
that i mean well i mean images like in
general
images are stored as like a single array
right with many bands in them and so you
know
they have some rank or something but so
the the it's like
in a perfect world wouldn't it be nice
if you could have an association
with keys for the different bands and
image you know uva or whatever it is
as opposed to the fact that we're
storing this you know rgb alpha
as you know one two three four elements
if i'm not mistaken yeah we always just
store them as channels we don't give
them names or anything yeah
right i mean for remote sensing giving
names would be nice
yep i agree probably yeah
so that's a separate issue is could
image be generalized so that you could
have
a uh a collection of layer names or
something
where you could access the layer name
separately and where this color separate
would give an association rather than a
list
right well i think that the right i mean
there are a couple of features you know
if you sort of imagined a more
generalized image that would be nice for
this
i think the features that that more
generalized image would have it would
have units
it would have you know it would have it
so you can have arbitrary numbers of
bands and you can do things like tell it
band 2 is the alpha channel of my eight
bands or something like that
um and then right it would probably have
named channels
named bands or whatever you want to call
it and what yeah so
because some functions treat the alpha
channel especially
what kinds of functions treat the alpha
channel especially
i think the only ones are very explicit
remove alpha channel
alpha channel and so forth um
however well all functions do something
with alpha channel things like binarize
first blend alpha channel into image and
then binarize
and then some functions you know which
elf which is the alpha channel to be
able to do right
right yeah okay i think there might even
be functions like
image add might also do some things i'm
not totally sure i remember though when
i was playing with this that
i sort of got you know burned a few
times by by
by you know giving it images and having
it not know what the alpha channel was
and it doing something really
weird so yeah there is a project that we
are going to look at
how we how different functions behave
when they
are fed with images with alpha channel
to make it a little more consistent
and document the behavior so whether we
blend or
take the alpha from one or the other or
whatever other behavior
or just process the alpha channel in
some cases so let's take another
issue here so the next issue so there
are two issues that i understand
there's what are the actual geo
coordinates and
then there's a projection but then
there's also let's interpret
these quotes color values in terms of
some units
is that right is that chris where is
that what
yeah sure i mean they're calling them
color values so
right often you'll have it so that
you'll have a band and the band you know
it'll be in some units but it's not
you know if you're talking about color
values i don't know if you mean like
something something like you have a
three channel image and you say that
red means this that would be very
unusual but just something like if you
have
three bands and you say you know these
are the units for each band
that would be much more common but yeah
what's an example of units that might be
given
i mean you could have i mean a very
common one is units of reflectance
which is you know uh just sort of a
ratio
um but then there's also stuff like you
know temperature
you have some temperature you have some
vegetation index and that's in whatever
weird units it's in
you know you have a map of primary
productivity and that's in some other
weird units
right something like vegetation
index isn't that an index like a number
right yeah but unity go ahead well i
guess vegetation index
might in which case it would probably be
some sort of independent unit or
something like that
but something like primary productivity
has like
primary productivity has actual units
would you like dollars per hectare or
something
it's like carbon dioxide grams of you
know
carbon dioxide per you know per area or
something like that
okay okay jose sorry
um i was going to say that something
very common is to provide
elevation profiles as your deep images
and those
uh the pixels are just elevations and
and then you need to know where those
numbers are you know feet or meters
whatever okay so question for more
generally for images
if we had the possibility of having
a units concept for images
so that image data for example could
maybe this is crazy but
is there a desire to have image data
have the possibility of getting out a
quantity array
i mean it seems like it seems like okay
because there's a question of like
what is the difference between an image
and a numeric array
let's say right i mean the question is
i mean fundamentally they're the same
thing they're just you know one of
them's a rapper around raw rays or
whatever
um and so it's sort of like honestly i
think it would be probably
more useful to have something like you
know uh a quantity version of numeric
array or some way of having you know
quantities associated with numerical
rays
and being able to have lots of nice
operations on numerical rays
you know and then you know right i mean
the only issue with that is the fact
that you want to be able to do all these
operations like binarize and so on
which only know how to work on images
and the default display is an image
display
for the geo stuff typically i mean even
if you're looking at an ultraviolet band
or something
or a primary productivity thing you you
typically would want it to display
as an image wouldn't you well but often
you have to like reconstruct it so i
mean sure if it's just like an rgb image
then that's easy but if it's you know
you have your data and it's got
20 bands you have to tell it what you
know i mean obviously you can have
defaults but like
you're gonna it's gonna have to
re-jigger the image a little bit to say
this is gonna be the red band this is
gonna be the green band this is gonna be
the
blue band and so on right
yes yes well okay so that processing is
another thing that geo raster could take
care of
that is yeah i mean that could have a
display function
or or i mean it should probably just
have an option like graph layout you
know or it's just an option that changes
how it displays
right which says of these different you
know what is the color
i mean if you've got eight bands how do
people typically display that
do they typically you know like convolve
that with a purple another one with a
pink another one with
something else so how do they do that i
mean the things that i've seen it's just
that they'll just say
band two is red band five is green
band six is blue and then they'll ignore
the other bands the other bands won't be
displayed
will they have will they will they have
a control on the display that says
you know bring up a different band it
probably depends on what
software you're using but i mean that
might be nice
okay and it's but that's and that's a
dynamic i mean
we we don't have that so shoddy i mean
right now we we have not really been
dealing with i mean
our image functionality has the nice
feature that can deal with any depth of
image
but any but but i don't think we've
really built that out particularly
no no but i think one of the things
that's been on the
uh wish list for a long time has been um
functionality maybe an option in the
image construct that can
tell us how to do the mapping from n
channels to
three channels something like a color
mapping
matrix or transformation some some
option of that sort that says how to do
the transform
from 12 channels to three
right and maybe maybe just you know as a
wishlist
item i mean it would also be nice if
there was you know a related option
that's like
channel four is the alpha channel or
something like that or maybe you could
just be embedded in that matrix
well so so what we're talking about then
is something which is some kind of
um image display
function or something or image display
mapping
and then that would what no i was just
maybe like channel mapping or something
like that
channel mapping
and maybe the simplest one would
probably be you just give it a list of
length three where you say one comma
three comma six and then the next one is
the matrix
well actually something like this where
that's the alpha channel there
or you could presumably give a function
well but the thing is i don't i think
the alpha channel like in that case i
think you might want the alpha channel
to be separate or maybe you give an
association there because what if you
have two bands
you know or what if you have three bands
it's band one band two and alpha channel
right and there's no i mean also you
could say something like this you could
just have none
if you don't want anything mapped to
blue
i guess so yeah i think that's more
explicit right
because at the end you really want to
map this to an rgb image
um so christopher is it typical that
they're using
a separate alpha channel or are there
also cases where it zeros out
you know the unit for missing type data
uh i'm not i'm not totally sure what you
mean i mean usually like at least in the
programs i've seen that do this like
remote sensing stuff
usually they do have an alpha channel or
sometimes they have an alpha channel
sometimes they just have a missing data
number um right i know that i looked at
like ozone data which
you know the file format dates to like
the 70s or whatever so it's pre
image stuff um and so they're
whatever they're measuring you know but
is you know
represented as an integer integer
between
you know zero and a thousand basically
um
and typical values are several hundreds
but you know where it's missing you know
they just are using zero
in their data right well so so i mean
okay so there's some question about how
you know is there a missing data
function which is what we have for some
other machine learning kinds of things
how does that work um but but let's
let's just let's just understand here
so we've got things like this um
clearly in addition to this we've also
got the color map right
for an image we've also got the the
notion of a color map like cmyk
for example as david is commenting on
our live stream about
um what is what is that what is the name
of the option for that
space okay
so in color space cmyk what happens i
don't quite understand what happens
there that then means that there are
four
four components for the image and that
will define the display right
correct okay so it is in fact more
complicated even
yeah so the image channel mapping then
feeds into the color space
um you know that that really might have
something that mentions color space
because
it is ultimately going to feed it into
the color space is it not
for for things beyond beyond the
human visible so to speak what do you do
for color space
in other words if you've got an eight
channel image what are you doing what is
what do you say so the default is it
says automatic
and i think it i'm not sure exactly how
it displays it but it does display it
in some way which i think is different
from just taking the first four
we're taking this yeah it's some
partitioning of all the channels into
the
three display channels or three rgb
channels okay so so
this has to be the image channel mapping
has to somehow be convolved with color
space to do something sensible
because that has to be a combined
concept i think do you agree
i mean maybe it could even be in the
color space option somehow
yes yes perhaps that that maybe the
color space isn't something like um you
know
uh
something like that or something go
ahead shoddy
i was gonna say it only makes sense with
color space automatic when we don't have
the specific named color space
well no because i think you you want to
be able to say you want to be able to
say
both channel one is red pam two is you
know channel six is green channel
five is blue but you also wanna be able
to say channel one is
cyan channel two is magenta etc no i
understand that but with
like i'm saying with color space
settings we have some named color spaces
like cmyk
rgb lab and so forth but the but the
all of those named ones have displayed
default displays
that we use and we should use it only
makes sense for
data that is or image that doesn't have
the explicit color space so if
if we have actually multi-channel
arbitrary images
without an explicit color space we can
go
with something like that hey by the way
i'd just like to report for somebody
there's a bug that we're not bringing up
the
the um help raft for the for in this
configuration
for color space it should bring up the
help the the eye
thing here somebody got that i don't
have to report that do i
oh i got it okay um
okay anyway look with the um
so actually to a slightly earlier point
i forget
i forget exactly who who said this but
but the thing about missing data values
versus alpha channels
um one issue is that sometimes different
bands will have different coverage
right so like maybe you have you know
maybe you have three bands you know this
one is temperature this one is
cloud cover this one is you know i don't
know
elevation and the elevation one is
defined everywhere
the you know the the cloud cover one
though might only be defined or like the
temperature one might only be defined
where there are no clouds
or something like that yeah so i'm not
sure if that's also something that you
have to handle i mean
alternatively you could always get
around that by just having multiple geo
rasters each with their own alpha
channel but
it might be nice if there was some
missing data the first question here
is units for images it seems to me
that having metadata having a
standardized way to store units for
every channel
is not completely silly
and that then one could expect to get
out
i mean like for example one could even
imagine something where you say
quantity array of image and it would
bring out the quantity array
that is the thing with the units for the
image
that crazy and if the image is unit less
can
quantity array still represent that data
i think so i mean like an intensity i
think it's just
quantity array is just then it then just
doesn't have any units i mean
the the the null quantity is the
quantity without units i don't know what
quantity does when it doesn't have units
what does it do
well it converts into a number and
quantity array does the same
but we could invent a dimensionless unit
that is preserved
how does it i don't even understand how
this works what does it do yeah
how do i get no you can say
dimensionless
for example on the menstrual cell unit i
think it's called
why doesn't it auto complete
it's a bug can you report it please
addison
screenshot report yep i got it
okay all right okay right so i think
what the array does the same
if it's purely dimensional dimensionless
we don't want to have two
representations of exactly the same
thing
right okay fine uh hold on i mean
how is uh so how
i'm not sure exactly how functions like
image apply and stuff like that are
going to work
on images with units right so i mean for
example
like first of all if you somehow did
something and you could do something
with an if statement where you have
different pixels have different units
associated with them in which case
that's
kind of hopeless right or topless i
think it has to be that a given
a given channel has is associated with
the with a particular unit
but like binarized by the rise of um
i don't know uh temperature unit
then doesn't make sense right how does
that finerize across rgb how does
how does how does it combine the quotes
are quote start g
quotes b units if one's a temperature
one's a carbon dioxide level one's or
something else
how does it well maybe we should just
maybe we should just say
that uh that that you know you've got
you got one unit for the whole image you
don't get to pick different units for
different bands
because
look why not just say binarize is
something that operates at the level of
the
uh you know quantity magnitude it
doesn't care about units
binarize is just not going to pay
attention to if one's centigrade
you know it's magnificent if one of
them's in centigrade one of them is in
fahrenheit
and you binarize across that and it
should you know should convert them well
tough luck it isn't going to do it
it's just going to treat the thing like
quantity magnitude well for at least
single channel images you definitely
want to be able to use the second
argument of binarize to give it a
quantity if this were a thing
oh i see i see i see right right so you
say you say something like binarize
the image and then you say you know
40 degrees centigrade or something yeah
but
hold on the question is though what what
operation would you ever do with an
image
that has different units for the
different channels right it's like you
can imagine something like
here i have the primary productivity and
units of whatever and here i have the
temperature i'm going to divide these
and i'm going to get something
some coherent thing out but if i had
some image that was you know those two
things as separate bands and some other
image with some other things a separate
band
it's like what am i ever going to do to
combine these it's going to produce
something coherent other than just
extracting the bands i care about and
then doing operations with them
fair point it's probably okay
um let's see we have various comments on
our live stream steve
coster is is uh commenting on
uh several comments here might want to
define what blue
is in the input and output in terms of
response curve from the instrument
on the bird as he refers to it which
um and what the display does in other
words
the satellite might have a different
sensor from
the display blue but we we already have
that issue right that's what color
profiles are all about isn't
it although i guess it i don't know i've
never used the color profile stuff but
it's often more general like
for these different satellites you can
get out like here's the response curve
for you know uh radio waves
or for you know ultraviolet you know and
stuff like that so i don't know maybe
the color profile stuff can handle that
well it's an interesting question
whether color profile data could be
generalized to deal with the remote
sensing stuff
i suspect the answer is yes but um
because this has device color space
right
and that that that is the kind of thing
that's needed there
um okay let's see
um let's see might have the
okay so steve is also commenting that
the blue band on one satellite might not
be the same
as the um uh the blue band from another
satellite
well i think that's again that's in the
category of if you really care about
that then
if we had named channels you would be
able to say
you know landsat 7 blue or something
presumably
how do they designate those is that
um well i think it depends on the format
it's like the usually
like the two main formats that i've seen
at least that modern
systems use is there's geotiff and
there's hdf5
or hdf4 or net cdf4 or whatever
and uh geotiff uh
i think geotiff supports like
you you can't i don't think geotiff
actually really supports like named
bands and stuff like that it's just kind
of like
you can have some metadata like of
course the geo reference and also
the uh you know i think you can have
units
um but then the actual image is just
like a big array
um and for example you know if channel
one
is you know in the form of like integer
16
then so is channel 3 it's on but then
these things like
uh these other ones like hdf5 which
allow you to have
more complicated things where you know
bands are named and they're in different
you know they're in different encodings
and stuff like that
but honestly i think in the second case
i think that i would argue that geo
raster should
should represent a geotiff and that if
you have things with different encodings
and different units they should be
separate geomasters
but whatever fair enough i mean look
this is a good example of where
named channels would be really nice
right rather than just referring to
these by number just being able to name
the near-infrared channels and so on um
i mean that could be something that you
could just have in geo raster though i
mean you could just say
i mean you could have your image or your
you know your uh
your your numeric array or whatever is
representing the data and then you know
if you have some function that's sort of
like uh you know you could have some
function for extracting
you know the coastal channel or
something right but i mean the other
point is for the color profile data
there's ultimately going to be a
convolution each one of these defines a
convolution of some kind and you're
adding those together somehow
and then deconvolving by some kind of uh
you know device color space thing
it's a little bit complicated but okay
this is okay that that's a separate
issue
let's talk now about the i mean we got
to resolve this and we're not going to
get it all resolved today especially so
not because i have a cut off um in not
too long here
um but now what we've got to do
okay so so so i think
an important question here is how much
of all of this goes into image itself
and how much
goes into uh geo raster or i was
suggesting there that
perhaps it should be image itself i i
don't know how much we would
we would break if we try to follow the
president of geographics that contains
in output a graphics inside
so perhaps your image could contain an
image inside and add
your information what do you mean the
geo image
that in the same way that the
geographics of input returns a
geographic
of graphics plus the oil information
the image of input could return at your
image of image plus jio information and
so we
don't make image to
contain all this information or perhaps
i mean
right now i think the ideal would be if
image can contain
geo meta information and we just
make the geo functions look for that
no i think that's i i don't like that i
mean i think that look i think there's
separate reasons to want to deal with
multi-channel images and units and
images and so on
that they're going to be relevant for
you know units and images could be
relevant for some
i don't know you know ultrasound image
that has i don't know pressure
values or something like this and all
kinds of reasons why people might use
images
that have nothing to do with the geo
stuff and projections and all those
kinds of things
so i think what we were talking about is
things that might be useful both in
in in geo raster and an image
if that makes sense but the things for
geo rest are those specials geo raster
are all of the geometry by the way let
me ask a question
the the the um
the business about spheres and
uh you know instead of geographics the
whole business about
um i'm sorry like geo distance things
like sphere distance and so on
is that what is the status of that in
other words
non-non-geo-related
spherical geometry right so
that's an ild project on my plate so i'm
okay it's fine it's
partially developed but i mean but
that's is that going to lead to a whole
other raft of functions
like how would you project
a you know you want something which is a
a sphere image somehow
so at the moment we are or i'm only
working on the
on the on the computational part and the
mathematical
uh part the same question appears for
example
or will appear with astra so how do we
uh represent all the astro situations
which are also essentially spherical
uh so we're getting an astral raster as
well
right so there are or visualization
functions so
so this is a question of how can we uh
funnel all these cases through something
in common
right well or at least have the same
principles for all of them because they
may be somewhat different i mean like
the
the um okay but let's go back to this
so the one thing that seems fairly clear
is that
a geo rasta
of okay so you could say geo raster of
some
uh of you know spain or something
and what do you get out do you get a geo
do you get something which is a a
symbolic representation which is
ultimately rendered as an image
so that if you zoomed on it it would
zoom correctly or what do you get
as opposed to geoimage where you just
run it once and you get an image back
so i i would argue that geo raster
you know if there was an independent geo
raster then it should just represent
like jim it just be like this is the
array these are the bytes
right maybe separately it would be
interesting to have some other symbolic
rapper thing that's sort of like a
basically some symbolic version of the
geo server
where you can kind of say like this
represents raster data
you know that's not that's not stored in
memory but where you can sort of request
it
and you can request it at a particular
resolution in a particular projection a
particular
you know range but i think that's a
different okay
i mean there's operations that could be
done symbolically on
on these you know lazy rasters so to
speak that haven't yet been rendered
with bits
because there are things you could do
you know the way that things are
combined the transformations and so on
might not even depend on what the actual
imagery is i was going to say would
something like geoarray be a better
concept
well i don't know i don't think i don't
think that's no because i think that
that isn't
you know in the end i mean in the end
that's what
that's sort of what we're looking at
right i mean we're looking at you know
i mean it's multiple layers of
array data but it's very image oriented
it is um i i just don't like raster
in the name so yeah well maybe one one
maybe one slightly awkward argument for
raster actually i think jose you might
have mentioned this in
email would be that you could have it so
that
you know geo image returns an image
georaster is a geo raster object
and you can put a geo raster and a
geographics and it will sort of display
beautifully um in that and in that way
you can sort of think of it as a
graphics primitive which is sort of like
raster but i know raster is kind of
deprecated
so but it's not it's not resolution
independent is it
i mean the geo raster you're saying it
if you say geo raster of spain it
retrieves the bits
at that resolution and that's all you
have
right but you absolutely want to be able
to say geographics of i don't know
something you know maybe the georaster
by itself maybe with some wrapper around
it
and then have it display the georaster
sort of laid on top of the
if the geographic's geo range is tiny
and it's just
doing one corner of one field here yeah
then i think it should just cover
it should just cover one corner one
field no i understand that but the
the pixels in this geo raster if they
have already been retrieved
all you've got there is you know two
pixels for the field or whatever
potentially you get you know a couple of
really big looking rectangles or you
know
distorted rectangles or something no but
is that right or should it instead be
a thing that says no i want to re you
know
the look that it's essentially something
that is more like
definitely not because for example a
large fraction of time if you're doing
any sort of remote sensing thing
you're probably going to be getting
these as geo tips or something
from some random website you're going to
be importing them as geo rasters
there's no world in which it's going to
like go back out to this website
and get a different resolution okay all
right because i mean the base map so to
speak could be at different resolutions
so i think what we do for that is that
geo styling has a geo server option so
we can start we could we can style
the interior of any polygon and then
geographics will decide what's the most
appropriate resolution
from that server
fair enough um okay
and if it's something that gets used
as a primitive within geographics then
i'm okay with raster and the name but if
it's you know some
something that does stuff on its own
then well it can have a display form on
its own while still being usable
in geographics right i mean this is the
thing though it's a little
it's a little bit of a disingenuous
thing because it's like you know
oh look it's it's a primitive in
geographic that's why it's called raster
but 95
of the time it's not a primitive in
geographic and you're just doing
operations on it independently
you know steve is making another point
here which is which is maybe
we should consider some version of one
of these things which can ship with
which can have multiple zoom levels of
its imagery inside it
again this is sort of this idea about
having kind of a lazy thing that's sort
of like a symbolic version of a joseph
which i think is interesting but i think
it should be different
okay but i mean this particular issue
here
given a geo raster the question is
you've taken that raster
so geo image you can request in any
projection you want
correct yes you're doing it right here
okay the only thing is it doesn't store
that projection so
all you have is the bit it does it does
but
information exactly yeah okay but then
but what we're asking for in geo raster
is something where
it more intelligently can combine you
know it knows if you've got so
so like just like show if you've got
this thing
in winkle triple and another thing in
mercator
that if you say geo raster of the two of
them together
it will do the right thing of you know
using
probably the first projection of any of
them just like show does
to make you know to do the right thing
but i think my point is that perhaps if
we do it inside geographics or geoimage
they can be trying to look for that meta
information
right there basically somehow you don't
need this wrapper you could just have it
so that when you call
your master reply or i don't know
whatever functions would exist
that they would just look at the image
you know look at the metadata and
complain if the metadata doesn't exist
right i really don't like this thing
about hiding the stuff in the metadata i
think it's going to cause us trouble
because even extracting how do you
extract the metadata can you say
information of image
comma geoprojection for example
i think you first have to get out the
metadata right and then you can it's an
association
at the top of the notebook of how does
it look
yeah yeah see that's kind of messy i
mean you know we definitely want to
not have that level of arbitrariness in
that
i would also argue that there are
probably some functions like
binarize or like you know i i don't know
there's some or like maybe show
which should probably work on on geo
rasters
in a very different way from how it
would work on an image and there's sort
of a
it might be a weird thing if just you're
sort of confused i have two images that
look identical and for some reason here
show works and here it doesn't and stuff
like that
well wait wait does show work on image
no
probably it doesn't what is the image
to graphics if anything i see and then
puts just a graphics wrapper around it
which then means it can be included in
graphics can't it
well i'm not sure show works on images
they might actually complain
but yeah i'm i'm not sure i mean show
does that with
other things it does it it does work
with images but
okay so if i say for example if i if you
call if you call
i mean again there's the fact that we
probably won't have quantities with the
geo rasters and maybe
quantity images could be a thing later
on i'm not sure but or for example if
you call
you know times maybe time
stephen what's that head of percent
right yeah no you can add axes and
everything
i guess
so but if for example you multiplied
together two geo-rasters
i think that there's probably some
default they could do you know i don't
know it picks the first one as the you
know to use its projection
something like that but but the idea
that you would multiply together two
images with different dimensions
for example like i think
that that's kind of strange if they're
if it's just that you're doing this and
and you just have to know that there's
some secret information hidden in the
image that makes it okay
right um i unfortunately haven't
have to go in a few minutes here um
we're we're not even going to finish
this first item
sadly uh this is what we get for
oh my gosh there's lots of stuff here um
oh boy we've got lots of other things to
discuss well is what we get for not
having one of these meetings for a few
weeks we haven't had one
for a few weeks have we or am i i think
end of
the last wow okay
well um
the uh okay
i see
area weighted pixel values that's just
because
if you if you get the if you want to do
things like make a histogram of
you know the heights of trees or i don't
know whatever thing you have a raster of
then the projection isn't necessarily an
equal area of projections you
technically should be using weighted
data
right right right i mean that's clearly
a very
significant reason to have the
geo-raster
concept um
ah yeah sl8 is commenting
where as soon as functions carry
yeah if the if the metadata is carrying
around important information we're
introducing a new paradigm which we
probably do not want to introduce
um okay we're not even going to get this
item finished unfortunately
so we have to return to this another
time
and um then we will get on to other
items but i think we should probably
wrap here for now unless we have just
one or two last comments about
giraffesta
no okay all right
thanks all here thanks to people on the
live stream and um
uh we'll continue another time